so as I said I have so much to catch you
up on from this weekend I took two days
off from all of this from time to time
this is really important to do so when
we were done on Friday early with the
show all the way through Sunday evening
I was basically trying to pay as little
attention as possible to what was going
on now it's difficult because every time
I do a zoom chat with my friends this is
what they want to talk about the virus
and I understand that but when I
reconnected with the news on Sunday
evening started to prepare today's show
an unconscionable amount of things had
happened over the weekend every day is
like a week in the old news era by which
I mean like three months ago before the
virus and at that point every week was
already like a month under Donald Trump
so these are strange times and as I told
you earlier Trump has been ranting about
the so-called the ratings of his
coronavirus press briefings despite the
fact that bodies are literally stacking
up and being a forklifted into the backs
of trucks one of the most tragic tragic
things we've seen in the United States
for a long time and this is another one
of those horrible examples that shows
Donald Trump's utter lack of concern for
the human toll it's really the absolute
worst of Trump that we've seen well Fox
News seemed to realize that yesterday
during the press briefing yesterday when
Donald Trump started ranting about his
ratings Fox News immediately realized
we've got a run interference here they
panicked they jumped in cut the audio
from Trump's briefing and reinterpreted
what it was that we were hearing only
coming back when Donald Trump was done
with that rant perfectly timed to run
interference for Donald Trump take a
look at this clip we shouldn't have
bigger ratings in The Bachelor or as the
New York Times said we have Monday Night
Football the president talking about
battling the coronavirus in a rose
garden ceremony for Americans who have
wondered how long life will go on the
way we've come to know at the last
couple of weeks the answer at least
another month April 30th now the target
date for the social distancing
guidelines this as America takes the
lead in the number of coronavirus deaths
worldwide please stay tuned to this Fox
station and Fox News Channel for
continuing coverage I'm John Scott in
New York
we will continue now on fox news channel
our coverage of the president's rose
garden ceremony news conference I should
say talking about the White House
response to the corona virus let's
continue to listen thank you very much
hilariously the interruption is an
anchor saying Trump is talking about
battling the virus no he's not he's
talking about ratings he's attacking the
New York Times he's saying that he's
getting the ratings of the bachelor and
Monday Night Football for these
completely unhinged gongshow press
briefings about the virus but you've got
to hand it to Fox it's sort of
beautifully done they didn't just cut
away they actually had an anchor
reinvent and reinterpret what Donald
Trump was saying Trump was ranting and
raving against the New York Times and
bragging about ratings and the
voice-over says we're watching Donald
Trump talk about fighting the
coronavirus which is not really what it
was that we were watching at the time
this is why Fox News viewers have no
idea what's going on and by the way I
might get to this more tomorrow Gabriel
Sherman is reporting that Fox News
executives are actually concerned about
legal liability they're worried they
might start getting hit with lawsuits
for downplaying the virus and spreading
propaganda for so long they ultimately
booted that lunatic trish regan who went
on that coronavirus hoax rant that it
you know it's not criminal but it feels
as though it should be and i'm not
literally saying that but it feels as
though which that rant that she went on
a couple weeks ago should have been
criminal in some way fox news is
concerned about the fact that they've
been downplaying this one of the
earliest purveyors of disinformation
spreading false and misleading claims
and they're now worried they could be
facing legal liability as a result of
their coronavirus coverage so there it
is
the full circle people are dying so
people become anxious mental health
issues are skyrocketing health care
workers don't have the equipment they
need we don't have masks and Trump is
bragging about his ratings which are
just scared people looking for some hope
some comfort and fox news runs
interference cutting away when Donald
Trump starts doing these absolutely
immoral sociopathic rants we are
effectively in a reality show and in
that sense Trump talking about The
Bachelor makes sense but people aren't
watching his press briefings like they
watch The Bachelor they're watching
because they're scared and unfortunately
seeing the incompetence of Trump every
day is only making people more scared
the latest approval ratings reflect that
and I hope to get to those tomorrow this
is an interesting media story if you've
been watching the White House
coronavirus press briefings you might
have noticed that there's a particular
seat in the back left of the room left
if you're looking from the lectern where
Trump stands which has frequently been
sort of like the lunatik media seat
often times there's a reporter from this
wacky right-wing media outlet Oh a n
that sits there one time Trump's former
press secretary Sean Spicer was sitting
there and we've circled that seat in red
in the image that we're showing our TV
and video audience the questions from
that seat are typically just ridiculous
sycophant ik Trump softball questions
but yesterday there wasn't someone from
Oh a n in that seat and it seems that
because of social distancing fewer seats
are being filled during these press
briefings but somehow at one point this
wacky oh way and reporter Chanel Rhian
asked the question anyway and she didn't
have a seat she was seen standing during
their the the press briefing so we
realized she was standing at the back of
the room we flagged her with a green
arrow in this next image and she asked
the question and it was sort of weird
that like everybody has a seat except
she's standing in the back and looks
very kind of disheveled it was really
weird well the White House
Correspondents Association has decided
to kick out o a n from the press room
altogether they've removed their seat
and issued a statement saying as you're
all aware the White House Correspondents
Association issued a policy last month
written last month
restricting seating in the room to
comply with CDC guidelines we've asked
reporters without a seat essentially
don't come to the briefings we are
writing to inform you that the White
House
Correspondents Association Board has
voted to remove a news outlet from the
rotation because a reporter twice
attended briefings in contravention of
this policy now of course they will
argue this is politically motivated all
of this other stuff but they are the
only ones showing up even when they
don't have a seat and yelling softball
sycophantic lunatic questions while
standing at the back of the room check
out some of the insane questions asked
by people in that seat I don't think
with Chinese Communist Party narratives
and they're claiming you're racist for
making these things about Chinese parts
is it alarming that major media players
just oppose you are consistently siding
with an Islamic gangs and cartels and
they were right here at the White House
with direct access to you in 13 it
amazes me when I read the things that I
read she can barely get the question out
and of course these are Looney cuckoo
for cocoa puffs questions here's another
one where they insert abortion and try
to compare this was Sunday I think try
to equate in some way death from the
virus spreading virally to death from
legal medical procedure abortion which
of course most Americans don't even
believe death is an accurate
characterization of here's the question
Sunday
[Music]
in the last 60 days meanwhile you have
2369 children who are killed by their
mothers through elective abortions each
day that's sixteen and a half thousand
children killed every week Tuesday's
have suspended elective abortion to make
more resources available for coronavirus
cases that's Texas in Ohio do you agree
with States who are placing coronavirus
victims above elective abortions and
should more states be doing the same
well I think we're doing is we're trying
to as a group governor's and that's
Republicans and Democrats yet we're just
working together to solve this problem
hilariously that one was actually too
crazy even for Trump to take the bait on
like when Trump finds the sycophant
except up questions too wacky to even
take seriously you know that you're
doing something wrong so this is
actually great news unfortunately you
know Oh a n shouldn't have a seat
period the fact that they had to lose it
by violating social distancing measures
okay they are worse than Fox News they
can't follow simple rules so they're out
but again they could simply force their
way back into the room they've been
showing up uninvited anyway without even
having a seat so really strange times in
which we are living and Oh a N and and
remember that trump has been sort of
praising Oh a n for a while now and he
seems gleeful when he calls on Oh a n
and often calls on them by names as the
S Oh a n beautiful question even Trump
has not taken the bait on some of their
wacky delusional questions this is a win
although for the wrong reasons they
should be kicked out because they aren't
a serious news outlet instead they're
being kicked out because they're showing
up and standing in the back to yell
questions even when they don't actually
have an assigned seat you'll take any
wins we'll take the wins no matter how
we can get him I guess is my view so
there's this wacky former judge she's a
pro Trump judge named Jeanine Pirro she
does a weekend show on Fox News I don't
I think it might just be a once a week
show but maybe it's like a Friday
Saturday and Sunday show but but I I
would I believe it's just once a week
she appeared extra
impaired and disheveled during her
program over the weekend and the
speculation that's running rampant is
that she seemed to be very very drunk um
first her show was delayed for technical
difficulties now presumably that
something related to something about her
socially distanced studio it was that
really a technical issue but when the
show started judge Jeanine was slurring
her words she looked visibly disheveled
at one point she appeared to be nodding
off while her guest was speaking and the
idea now is is it possible that Judge
Jeanine was actually drunk now whether
or not her drunkenness explains the
technical delay of the show we just have
no idea let's go to the first clip she
seems confused about what the next
segment is and as you can hear right
before but this is so crazy right before
the intro graphic cuts to her you
actually hear her yell to someone off
camera somewhere I can't before she
starts confusedly reading the
teleprompter take a look at this
[Music]
alright wait joining us every time that
they came back from a commercial break
she seemed more impaired
check this out and here is a very
labored teleprompter reading from Judge
Jeanine welcome back to justice just the
other day the president talked there was
hoping about the possibility of
reopening everything on Easter Sunday
and in a way where we could kind of come
out of this quarantine as loose as it
may be that were involved in and Lisa
Booth the Fox News contributor is here
to talk with us tonight about whether
that's even a possibility how are you
Lisa so alcohol is the main thing that's
being mentioned quaaludes was the other
thing being thrown around sort of a
throwback to the wolf of wallstreet era
at another point she appears to be sort
of nodding off while her guest talks her
head kind of leaning more and more to
her left until she seems to kind of be
startled back into a higher level of
coherence so it's very weird and anyway
who knows what this
exactly is but it keeps happening
remember that rudy giuliani's evening
appearances on fox news and other TV
stations were limited they tried to get
Rudy on during the day because his
evening drinking at dinner was becoming
a problem and he would then go on TV
after having had a few too many along
with one of those big cigars that he
likes last week maybe it was the week
before it's all blending together we saw
Trump economic advisor Larry Kudlow who
is known to have previously had pretty
severe drinking problems
he seemed impaired on television and now
judge Jeanine Pirro things are all just
crazy in the air of Carrera of
coronavirus and again I want to be
really clear alcoholism is nothing to
laugh at and in fact I think we need to
be taking extra care during this time to
mention a lot of people are under stress
anxiety depression cabin fever erratic
behavior because these are not normal
times I've never experienced anything
like this in my lifetime
most people alive today have never
experienced a sort of shutdown
quarantine isolation situation like this
at the global scale in in any of their
lifetimes and I understand turning to
whatever it is right some weird we're
hearing about people turning to benzos
we're hearing about people turning to
alcohol etc but whatever it is that's
going on at Fox News with the drinking
and the impaired 'no sand and
right-wingers who seem to be impaired on
TV it's getting a little bit weird and
it's more than just concerning let me
know what you make of the Jeanine Pirro
thing I have good news for you today in
that a bad person lost their job but
it's still all wrapped in terrible news
which is that Fox News is still
combining with the Trump administration
to continue spreading violent
disinformation about the virus I'm
talking now about former Fox News host
trish regan really a phial person trish
regan was until recently a Fox Business
Channel host she went on one of the most
unhinged Trump defending coronavirus
minimizing rants that we've ever seen
just a couple of weeks ago and Fox has
said bye-bye to her although we don't
yet know
exactly why check out the first part of
this bizarre rant everything about it is
wacky and deranged this was again a
couple of weeks ago when we knew this
was a crisis take a look we've reached a
tipping point the chorus of hate being
leveled at the president is nearing a
crescendo as Democrats blame him and
only him for a virus that originated
halfway around the world this is yet
another attempt to impeach the president
and sadly it seems they care very little
for any of the destruction they are
leaving in their wake
losses in the stock market all this
unfortunately just part of the political
casualties for them you know this is the
time to be united not to be pointing
fingers not to be encouraging hate and
yet what do we see we see the absolute
opposite from the left tonight good
evening everyone i am trish regan the
heat is boiling over many in the liberal
media using and i mean using coronavirus
in an attempt to demonize and destroy
the president this monologue which
should really be Exhibit A media
literacy classes for distinguishing
between news and opinion identifying
bias identifying unstable people maybe
in a psychology class
it went on for five minutes and really
it peaked at the end when Trish Regan
couldn't even keep her nonsense straight
off of the teleprompter sort of got lost
in her own teleprompter white while
continuing to in a completely unhinged
fact freeway defend Donald Trump and
minimized the virus here's the wrap up
to her lunatic soliloquy for the media
to spin a narrative that this sell-off
and this virus are all a result of
President Trump it's just wrong but
unfortunately I guess they needed
someone to blame they were looking for
someone to blame they want to blame him
for literally anything they can and they
have no real interest shall we say in
finding who's to blame who is the root
cause of all this from what we can tell
this all originated out of China
you know when Donald Trump is their
political target that's all they need
and that's tonight's Intel so the good
news is bye-bye trish regan the bad news
is fox is still a disaster it's also not
clear that this rant is why she was
fired it may be it may not be fox has
only been saying you know we thank Trish
and we wish her continued success so we
don't even really know the full reality
of it one idea is that trish regan may
sort of be like the sacrificial lamb for
all of fox news because you've got the
Fox and Friends clowns in the morning
talking about flying around and going to
restaurants and wanting to get their
nails done you have sean hannity talking
about how vaping might protect you from
coronavirus and suggesting unproven
prophylactic treatments for the virus
according to reporter gabriel sherman
fox news is actually worried about
possible legal liability for their
coronavirus downplaying so maybe they're
tossing trish regan out of there to say
hey listen we took it seriously
we pulled her off the air we cut ties
with her we did the right thing while
allowing everybody else to continue
spouting the nonsense so that's trish
regan we do have one more fox news
related story today which is about that
lunatic right wing judge Jeanine Pirro
who appeared visibly drunk during her
weekend program also presumably being
produced from her home at this point so
let's talk about that one next hey I
think you're gonna like this this is a
little bit of a break from the
persistently depressing news for only
slightly depressing news that also has a
funny component so Fox News brings on a
doctor and the doctor is interviewed by
anchor Martha McCallum the doctor was
completely unwilling to accept even a
little bit of Martha McCallum's bogus
framing of questions
he gave her a 60 second answer that
instantly shut down the interview martha
maccallum saying right away
thanks doc we'll talk to you later so
let me set this up for you this is dr.
richie desai he's the chief medical
officer at
Moses Dr Desai is an expert in
infectious disease much like Anthony
foutch II Dr Desai is not just a doctor
but he is a doctor who specializes in
exactly what we're dealing with here the
corona virus pandemic dr. Desai recently
led Khan Academy's medicine portal we're
talking about a scholar and academic a
doctor and he will not take Martha
McCallum's BS martha maccallum frames up
a question about you know we're told
about millions of tests being available
dr. Desai immediately starts just
shaking his head no and then in 60
seconds explains basically everything we
need to know about the testing fiasco we
knew about the issue of testing for a
long time we knew the virus was coming
we did nothing while South Korea did
everything check this out this is how
you ensure no follow-up questions from
fox news anchors now what we hear every
night is that the test that there are
millions of tests available and yet we
don't have that pin prank blood test
that you can just sort of get you know
at your local doctor in know in 15
minutes but they're yeah they're working
on it they should have no work on it for
months so the fact is we knew about this
from the WHI went December 31st 2019 so
last year we knew about this we knew
coronavirus is coming we knew as the
restroom disease we knew as person
person why is it that it's this week
that the FDA finally approved these kind
of new Abbott lab testing which by the
way is one test at a time it's a great
test but it's one test at a time it's
different than labs that are doing mass
testing right so this is a wonderful
test don't get me wrong but it's one
test for 15 minutes
that's wonderful but it's not the same
volume that you really need this is
better for kind of outpatient clinics
and things like that we needed this
months ago you look at Korea Korea South
Korea and the u.s. had their first
official confirmed case on the same date
January 19th
let me nineteen you look at what South
Korea did and what we did their
population is one-sixth of ours look at
the cases they have look at the
mortality they have it's a trifle
compared to what we're dealing with
right now
because we've had a very weak response
and they had a really strong response
doctor thank you very interesting to
talk to you dr. Desai I hope you'll come
back as we move through this difficult
period in the country dr. Desai thank
you very much sir
so martha maccallum goes silent and ends
the interview no follow-up just buh-bye
back to Donald Trump's propaganda claims
now there's speculation that that delay
when dr. Desai stops speaking before
martha maccallum starts speaking was
because the producer was in her ear
telling her end the interview and wrap
it up
that's an interestingly dramatic
romanticized kind of narrative it might
have just been a delay with dr. Desai's
connection we don't really know but
visually very very compelling and again
regarding the tests this is a really
important point that dr. Desai makes the
Abbott point of care test that takes 15
minutes it's a really great thing that
we have this because it's great for
healthcare providers to be able to run
the tests in-house rather than having to
send them out it reduces the amount of
time that you have to wait for any one
individual test but it's important to
understand as dr. Desai points out the
machine can run one test at a time the
results take 5 to 15 minutes that means
you can test for people per hour that's
not good in a lot of ways particularly
in a lot of these more densely populated
areas so you know it's it's a good thing
that the test is a point-of-care test
that it can all be done in-house but at
the same time a lot of these other tests
are done in large swaths you can test a
huge number of samples at once get a lot
of people results very quickly if you
have several hundred people that you've
tested and you can only run four per
hour through a machine you're still
going to get a huge amount of backup any
new testing capacity is good very
important to understand but dr. Desai
accurately pointing out that as with
almost everything Donald Trump is
obviously over selling it we'll have
more coverage of testing on the David
Pakman show instagram page at david
pakman show while you're there check out
my Instagram David Pakman I'll soon be
filming a full behind-the-scenes of the
home studio which I think a lot of
people are going
look at very strongly that's my that's
my expectation anyway hey so this is
weird
it seems that Donald Trump doesn't
understand the concept of per capita for
the last 10 days or so Trump keeps
bragging about how much the US is
testing for the virus and every time he
does he's ignoring the concept of per
capita or at least we thought he was
ignoring the concept of per capita
because it wasn't politically convenient
but based on yesterday's press
conference I'm increasingly thinking
Trump doesn't understand what per capita
means per capita of course is when you
adjust numbers for the size of a
population so if I say to you you know
the United States and Colombia both gave
away a hundred million dollars to people
in stimulus money per capita in the u.s.
that's 29 cents per person in Colombia
it's $2 per person because Colombia and
the US have different populations if we
say you know we did a million
coronavirus tests and South Korea did
500,000 might sound like we did more but
per capita South Korea did way more
because South Korea's population is much
smaller than ours we have 340 million
people in the u.s. South Korea has about
50 million people so check this out
yesterday reporter yummy shhhhh Alcindor
asked Trump about this and Trump says
we're testing more than anyone and you
Miche raises the issue of per capita and
Trump doesn't seem to get it he wrongly
states the population of Seoul South
Korea he talks about how we have rural
areas in the United States and it only
gets funnier and by funnier I mean more
tragic because we laugh to avoid crying
in these difficult times take a look at
the first part of the video
mr. president you said several times
that the United Sates is ramped up
testing but the United States is still
not testing per capita as many read as
many people as other countries like
South Korea why is that and when do you
think that that number will be on par
with other countries very much fun part
look look what per capita we have areas
of country that's very wait I know South
Korea better than anybody it's a very
tight you know how many people are in
sold you know big the city of Seoul is
thirty-eight million people okay so
that's like ten seconds from Trump and
there are just so many things to look at
there Trump mentions hey but hold on a
second we have rural areas in the United
States and Seoul South Korea is really
dense per capita accounts for the
population that's the point of per
capita Trump is acting like the fact
that we have rural areas means we are
testing more per capita no we're talking
about how much are we testing relative
to the population which includes rural
areas and densely populated areas you
Miche is at least trying to talk about
per capita then Trump says he knows
South Korea better than anyone which is
another one of those hyperbolic lies but
then again immediately he miss states
the population of Seoul saying Seoul has
a population of 38 million for a guy who
knows the most about South Korea it's
weird not to know the population of
Seoul so it didn't sound right when
Trump said 38 million I looked it up
seoul's population is only 9 million
almost 10 million so I thought well
maybe Trump was referring to the metro
area the Seoul metro area but that's
only 25 million so I thought well maybe
Trump meant all of South Korea has 38
million but no as I mentioned earlier
South Korea has about 51 million people
so then and this is just too funny if
you google Seoul South Korea this quick
facts things thing pops up and it says
38 M but that's the elevation of Seoul
38 metres above sea level or 125 feet is
it possible Trump is confusing
population and elevation or is he just a
[ __ ] who doesn't know anything in South
Korea is a not he's not actually an
expert in South Korea and he doesn't
understand the concept of per capita
maybe that's the most likely explanation
you be the judge here's the rest of the
back and forth with journalists Amisha
Alcindor that's bigger than anything we
have 38 million people all tightly-wound
together we have vast farmlands we have
vast areas where they don't have much of
a problem in some cases they have no
problem whatsoever we have done more
tests what I
I didn't talk about per capita we have
done more tests by far than any country
in the world by far our testing is also
better than any country in the world
so again Trump talking about how hey but
we have rural areas but again per capita
accounts for the total population and
the number of tests adjusted to the size
of that population imagine having a
president imagine having a president
here's an interesting sort of a
political story it's a break this is a
political show it's a break from the
virus coverage and it's about democratic
New York congresswoman Alexandria Acacio
Cortez she's getting crushed by a
portion of the left a portion of the
left that widely supported her for a
long time at least until recently and
the reason AOC is getting crushed is she
is taking what she sees as a more
pragmatic approach to the progressive
movement and it's a really really
interesting story that has divided the
online progressive left over the last
few days this all started because there
are a whole bunch of primary challenges
by progressive Democratic candidates
against more centrist Democratic
incumbents AOC hasn't endorsed many of
those progressive challengers she's
chosen a couple of sort of easy ones in
Texas and Illinois where the opponents
are really conservative Democrats who
oppose abortion but otherwise aoc has
stayed out of a lot of these races
aoc has also had quite a bit of turnover
in her staff a lot of those sort of
outspoken young progressive activists
that were working for aoc have been
replaced with some more moderate
professional political strategist
Democrats that often work with incumbent
Democrats now there are questions
increasingly about whether aoc
campaigned enough for Bernie
before super Tuesday's results that that
hurt Bernie and the second Super Tuesday
and the third Super Tuesday and the
virus ultimately keeping people at home
and a OC has also publicly shifted from
being very antagonistic towards Nancy
the Democratic Speaker of the House to
being more publicly laudatory and
positive towards Nancy Pelosi and a lot
of people have jumped on her for this
AOC has also jumped into criticizing
Bernie supporters for online harassment
that's been mostly the purview of
centrist Democrats and Biden supporters
and sort of DNC folks but AOC has said
yet a lot of that online harassment is
not good she said some of Bernie's
allies are to conflict based that also
rubbed a lot of Bernie supporters the
wrong way
AOC also launched a pact earlier this
year which is not looking to primary
centrist Democrats it's focused on
flipping red states to blue the the the
goal of a o'seas pact is not to find
centrist Democrats and replace them it's
to find red seats and turn them blue
replacing Republicans with Democrats now
I have to tell you this makes me see AOC
as much more clever and shrewd
politically as a political operative
than I imagined you guys many of you
criticize me occasionally for saying hey
you know AOC has a lot of the right
ideas but not the right political
practicality not the right political
approach I see that as changing here now
there's lots of people that are furious
about this TYT host John Cougar has gone
after AOC for this a bunch of others
have but let's think this through first
of all almost everyone changes when they
got elected and and this is why I always
say don't defy or glorify individual
politicians they are all elected by the
system we currently have and essentially
every single one of them to some degree
it varies but to some degree when they
become elected officials under that
system they will start to reap reinforce
or defend to some degree some elements
of the system that got them elected once
they get into power that applies to just
about everybody it doesn't mean that
they flip and abandon their values
that's not what I'm saying but that's
not the important analysis for me the
important analysis for me is that we
just got done talking about Bernie lost
not be
because his ideas are bad but because a
lot of the people around him are toxic
because of his relationship with those
in positions of power because the
country just isn't as overtly left as
Bernie Sanders for the last six weeks
we've been saying many of us the future
of the progressive movement is in
somebody with Bernie sensibilities
Bernie's values many of Bernie's policy
goals but who has a better team around
them fewer toxic people better branding
none of this democratic socialist stuff
the revolution language is not
particularly useful to Bernie aoc isn't
changing her political positions here
her view on Medicare for all hasn't
changed her view on the green new deal
hasn't changed she's changing her
approach maybe at least that's what it
seems like this is what we've been
talking about guys we don't need someone
who differs from Bernie on core values
Bernie has the right core values
AOC shares Bernie's core values nothing
has changed as far as that goes
AOC is doing exactly what Bernie didn't
do a OSI is doing something to get
around what ultimately led to Bernie
getting crushed on Super Tuesday and
then more on Super Tuesday too and more
on Super Tuesday three people keep
saying hey we need Bernie's ideas with
better framing packaging and public
relations that's what a OSI is leaning
towards here a OSI is looking to become
a force for change by building these
relationships where in the next six
years eight years she could have a long
laundry list of legislative
accomplishments
she's working within the system to
invoke change now that's an area of
disagreement Bernie has more of an
approach of destroying the system
revolution and then rebuilding it from
the ground up working within the system
has gotten us many important things gay
marriage Violence Against Women Act food
stamps Social Security Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau pre-existing
conditions coverage and being on your
parent's insurance until age 26 labor
laws birth control now has it been
enough no no way in hell has it also led
to bad things of course I mean you know
look at the Iraq war the Iraq war is the
epitome of working
within the system with centrist
Democrats in great part that got us the
Iraq war but when I see a OSI step away
from some of the absolutism of Bernie my
feeling is this will help her get things
done rather than being able to say we
tried this but we failed we didn't
actually get to do it I believe this
better positions AOC to actually get
things done to me this suggests a o'seas
political instincts are better than I
thought I underestimated her political
instincts until I saw this I'm ready to
get crushed my friends I'm ready for
people to disagree tell me all the ways
in which I am wrong but this this
actually improves my opinion of AOC
dramatically so the first case of
coronavirus globally that we know of
confirmed was January 10 the first case
in the United States was January 20 we
now have well over a hundred thousand
cases heading very quickly to two
hundred thousand cases it's been months
since this started and Donald Trump
still doesn't appear to know what
coronavirus is which is of course a
virus Donald Trump's almost daily Gong
Show press briefings have been truly
houses of horrors I've been covering and
live fact fact-checking most of them I
took like a mental health break over the
weekend but I did get this one moment
sent to me from the Friday one that I
have to show you which is Donald Trump
again in the way that only Donald Trump
can talking about something he doesn't
know about like no one knows about it
when in reality he's almost the only
person left who doesn't understand these
basic things about the virus here is
Trump saying is this a germ is it a flu
is it a virus no one really knows what
it is pandemic by this disease
this whatever they want to call you've
got it germ you can call it a flu you
can call it a virus you can call it many
different names I'm not sure anybody
even knows what it is is this ringing an
alarm to anyone else we're months into
this and Trump is saying things like
they don't really know what this is
you could also I guess call it the
Chinese virus which Donald Trump notably
has stopped saying clearly somebody got
to him and said that's enough with the
Chinese virus stuff how bad is this guys
is it the germ flu or virus no one knows
it's almost April this has been around
since January 10 with confirmed cases
Trump was briefed on it in December this
isn't funny anymore as if it ever was
it's a type of corona virus this is a
virus it's not the flu it causes
respiratory illness it spreads through
contact with infected people when they
cough or sneeze or through contaminated
surfaces coronavirus has been around for
a long time we've known about them a
long time it's not the flu the death
rate is higher the spread ability is
higher more people are dying daily every
day that we go but we have an increased
death toll from this and Trump is
lecturing about they don't even know
what it is we know you're just not doing
what needs to be done to fix it by and
large if Trump had said on December 30th
is it a germ flu or virus no one knows
you know I'd probably say he's at least
talking about it instead of ignoring it
to save this on March what was that 27th
or 28th when he said this whenever it
occurred over the weekend this is truly
the stuff of Horrors and the only thing
you know I I am NOT someone who looks to
criticize Trump for everything he does
when it doesn't deserve criticism Trump
made the right decision
not to open things up on Easter again
based on what he said yesterday it may
change by tomorrow Donald Trump said
were extending social distancing
guidelines until April 30th that's the
right decision now had this been started
earlier we might be looking at being
able to release some of those guidelines
earlier doesn't meant to be that as it
may this is
where we are and the right decision
today is that obviously we're not ready
to lift these guidelines in a few days
we're gonna have to go until April 30th
that's the right decision
Trump continuing to say things like is
this the germ is it a flu no one really
knows what it is is weaponized ignorant
problematic to the nth degree and it's
leading to Donald Trump continuing to
avoid blame and responsibility in any
way possible as I said earlier Donald
Trump implying or suggesting you know
maybe the reason we have a mask shortage
isn't because he failed but because
masks are being stolen by hospitals he's
going to continue doing this stuff and
in fact we now have more information
about why we have such a shortage and
it's not because of Obama let me tell
you that and I want to address that next